I think the lines that make the contents of this
loop repeat exactly once for each digit are while n is
greater than 0. And, n gets updated to n over 10.
Every time the code in these curly braces runs, n gets
integer divided by 10. So, whatever this last digit was, it
loses it. If n was 365, it loses the 5. If
it was 36, it loses the 6. Now, the code inside
of these braces runs over and over again, as long as
n is greater than zero. In other words, as long as n
has more digits. You could say that this line where we set n
is part of controlling the loop as well, since the size of
n effects when the loop stops. I would probably not say that the
line int digit equals n mod 10 is part of running the
loop once for each digit. This line doesn't change how many times the
loop runs, it is related though because this is how we actually
get the digits one at a time so we can add them up.